As the titular character of the drama series,
The Good Doctor, Dr. Shaun Murphy has faced
great adversity and made great triumphs.
These are the highest of the highs and the
lowest of the lows for Shaun and those closest
to him.
More than a year ahead of the COVID-19 pandemic,
The Good Doctor forced its doctors to deal
with a quick-spreading pathogen in the Season
2 fall finale episode "Quarantine."
The installment found St. Bonaventure's ER
on lockdown as a virus laid siege to the hospital.
The drama takes place as things are already
ramping up amid holiday madness, and the pressure
is already heightened for Shaun, who finds
the sensory assault of Christmas lights and
holiday chaos chipping away at his composure.
To make matters worse, hospital visitors begin
freaking out, emergency surgeries are needed,
Park's son has a severe asthma attack, and
some of the doctors are among those taking
ill.
Amid all of the frenzy, Shaun begins to hyperfocus
on a buzzing overhead light that continues
to break his concentration – a sign that
he is beginning to experience sensory overload.
"The light is buzzing."
"I don't hear anything."
"It's loud and very distracting.
It needs to be fixed."
Things reach a fever pitch when Lim collapses
while walking Morgan through surgery as Park
screams for someone to help his son.
Shaun finally hits his breaking point, covering
his ears and curling up in a fetal position
right in the middle of the emergency room
walkway as alarmed staff and patients look
on.
Although it's a scary moment for Shaun and
the nursing staff, Morgan's quick thinking
saves the day when she realizes that getting
him to focus on the surgery is just the thing
to help him calm down.
As a neurologically atypical individual, Shaun
sometimes struggles to communicate information
with the same ease as his neurotypical colleagues.
That's alright, however, because Shaun's other
workplace gifts far exceed the communication
challenges he encounters from time to time.
When Dr. Lim assigns Shaun his first surgery
in "First Case, Second Base," Shaun feels
confident even though his number one detractor,
Dr. Andrews, has doubts about whether Murphy
is up to the challenge.
Although the surgery starts auspiciously,
Shaun suddenly walks out of the operating
room halfway through the surgery.
"Can't do this!"
"What can't you do?"
"No!
No!
No!"
Shaun then proceeds to pace the hallway while
struggling to articulate what he's thinking
as a baffled Park, Andrews, and Lim look on.
Just as Andrews and Lim are concluding Shaun
is suffering a meltdown that demonstrates
how unfit he is for the job, a light bulb
goes off over Park's head as he realizes Shaun
is trying to tell them something.
After calming down, Shaun explains that the
patient, who would have been left with a feeding
tube as a result of the planned surgery, could
receive a more advanced operation – but
it would mean Shaun has to forfeit his case.
The moment demonstrates how capable Shaun
is of synergy with his colleagues, his ability
to overcome his own challenges, and his willingness
to put patients first.
From the moment Lea knocked on Shaun's apartment
door, it was clear they had chemistry.
Still, the path to true love isn't always
easy, and both Shaun and Lea had a lot of
growing up to do before they were ready to
start a relationship.
Things between the pair get rocky after Carly
breaks things off with Shaun, encouraging
him to tell Lea how he feels about her.
In the Season 3 episode "Autopsy," Shaun follows
Carly's advice and confesses his feelings
for Lea.
She is quick to reciprocate them but tearfully
says they can't be together, remaining silent
when he asks if it's because of his autism.
Shaun spends the next few episodes in a dark
hole and lashes out at everyone around him
in anger.
Eventually, he decides to vandalize Lea's
car in the hope that it will make him feel
better.
However, he can't bring himself to do it,
and instead delivers a brutal takedown, telling
Lea she doesn't respect him, no one likes
her, and she deserves to end up alone.
"You acted like you cared about me.
But you don't even respect me."
The interaction is distressing and cruel,
even if Lea badly needs a wake-up call to
confront her ableism and selfishness.
One of the things that made the early difficulties
between Shaun and Lea so painful is that Lea
wasn't just rejecting him outright.
She really does love him but genuinely worries
that a relationship between two high-maintenance
people would be far too difficult.
However, as she takes time to think things
over, her feelings for Shaun only continue
to grow, and she is finally forced to face
them when she fears she might lose him for
good.
The revelation comes in Season 3's penultimate
episode, "Hurt," which puts Shaun on the rescue
team in the aftermath of an earthquake that
leaves some of St. Bonaventure's people – including
Lea – trapped in a brewery.
Shaun sets out to rescue her but ends up helping
a woman named Vera instead.
While trapped and awaiting rescue, Shaun pours
his heart out to Vera without realizing that
Lea can hear him from a walkie-talkie.
Before he can bring her to safety, an aftershock
traps them both, flooding the sub-basement
as a horrified Lea listens in over the radio.
As Lea fears for his safety, Shaun pours out
his heart to Vera.
"Lea makes me more."
After Shaun's confession, an aftershock then
hits, flooding the basement and Shaun and
Vera are trapped in.
With their lives at stake, Vera convinces
Shaun to move on from Lea if they make it
out alive.
When he finally emerges from the building,
a waiting Lea greets him with a kiss, telling
him that he makes her feel the same way, having
finally realized how much better their lives
are together.
It's established early in The Good Doctor
that Shaun's parents failed him badly.
Shaun's alcoholic father was horribly abusive
to Shaun and his brother Steve.
He berated Shaun for his autism.
Eventually, he drove Shaun and his brother,
Steve, to run away from home, which leads
to Steve's accidental death.
With such a tragic backstory, it's little
wonder Shaun is hesitant to go see his estranged
father when he learns he has a terminal illness.
Although his father, Ethan Murphy, initially
apologizes to Shaun, he does so by playing
the victim, blaming his actions on his inability
to help his autistic son in "Friends and Family."
His words are triggering, causing Shaun to
unleash his anger, telling his father he's
a bad person.
"You killed my rabbit, and you killed my brother."
After sleeping on his anger, Shaun returns
to forgive his father, but Ethan responds
with more abuse, telling Shaun that he is
weak and it's his fault his brother died.
It's a dark moment in Shaun's life that reminds
Shaun the Murphys were never his family — except
by blood.
Shawn first meets Dr. Glassman after he and
Steve run away in search of a doctor for Shaun's
rabbit.
While Glassman can't save their pet, he gives
them his phone number in case they need anything,
which leads to Shaun to call him after Steve's
accident.
Although Shaun is eventually placed in foster
care, he remains in touch with Glassman, who
serves as a surrogate father and helps him
get hired at St. Bonaventure after medical
school.
Through the ensuing years, their relationship
faces various trials and strains, but they
remain close despite everything.
On Shaun's wedding day, Glassman gives Shaun
two rings passed down through his family that
he had intended to give his late daughter.
As Glassman attempts to tie Shaun's bowtie
for him, Shaun shares a touching sentiment
that highlights the importance each man has
in the other's life, even calling Glassman
his father.
"I love you, Dr. Glassman."
Although Shaun faces many challenges building
relationships at St. Bonaventure, he forms
a strong workplace friendship with Audrey
Lim.
However, their relationship sours after Shaun's
split-second surgical decision leaves Lim
partially paralyzed.
The trouble arises when Dr. Lim and another
doctor are attacked during Shaun's wedding
at the end of Season 5, forcing Shaun and
Glassman to perform emergency surgery with
the hospital still under lockdown in the Season
6 opener "Afterparty."
While operating on Lim, Shaun goes against
Glassman's order, performing a slightly riskier
procedure that saves her but causes her paralysis.
As she struggles to accept her new reality,
Lim targets her anger on Shaun, believing
his recklessness cost her the ability to walk
– a position that's unfortunately reinforced
by Glassman's own feelings about Shaun's decision.
When Shaun doesn't seem to understand how
resentful Lim is, she brutally spells it out
for him, telling Dr. Murphy that she no longer
wants to be friends in "A Big Sign."
"But that's all.
I don't want you to ask me about my personal
live, and I don't want to hear about yours."
Fortunately for all involved, Shaun is nothing
if not persistent, and he continues to work
on ways to get her mobility back despite Lim's
anger.
While Lim continues to harbor resentment toward
Shaun, she eventually begins to embrace her
new way of living with help from Danni, who
underwent a leg amputation years prior.
Despite the strain on their relationship,
Shaun's commitment to repairing Lim's nerve
damage pays off when he finds a way to get
her walking again.
However, Shaun has to make things right with
Lim first.
In the episode "Sorry, Not Sorry," he tells
her he does not owe her an apology, as he
did save her life, but admits he is sorry
the decision caused her harm.
He further opens up, telling Lim he misses
their personal relationship.
"I have missed your friendship.
I have missed you."
Lim reveals she's working through her anger,
but she's finally in a good place and misses
Shaun's friendship, too.
It's good to see Lim and Shaun makeup, but
more importantly, the moment shows Shaun's
growth as a surgeon.
Shaun's revelation that he isn't remorseful
or guilty while still expressing empathy for
Lim shows his humanity without compromising
his confidence in his ability to make the
hard calls he'll need to keep making going
forward.
Shaun and his colleagues find themselves in
the tug-of-war between quality care and financial
constraints when the St. Bonaventure is bought
by the overbearing Salen.
While she saves the hospital from financial
ruin, Salen shifts everything to a heavily
profit-driven system, and begins weighing
money over human lives.
At first, Shaun weathers the changes surprisingly
well.
While he tends to resist change, he can understand
the logic behind many of Salen's decisions.
However, when Salen's corner-cutting with
expired medications costs a baby her life,
Shaun's rage boils over in the episode, "Expired."
Triggered by the recent loss of his own infant,
he makes his way to the hospital pharmacy,
where he smashes bottles of expired medications
and lashes out at everyone around.
Feeling he can't trust anyone, blaming Glassman
for the baby's death and telling Lea that
he can't marry her.
"You lied to me.
I can't trust you, and I can't marry you."
While it's a dark moment that leaves a serious
rift in Shaun's relationship with Lea, the
meltdown marks a turning point that leads
to the staff's active rebellion against Salen.
One of the more heartbreaking storylines in
The Good Doctor is Shaun and Lea's painful
journey to parenthood.
As Lea's pregnancy progresses, they learn
they're having a baby girl and get excited
about their new family member.
However, their happiness falls apart when
Lea experiences a brutal late pregnancy loss
in "Dr. Ted."
Over time, the couple begins to move on past
their grief, eventually getting married and
looking forward to starting a family once
they get the medical okay.
However, Shaun and Lea are met with even more
bad news when they learn Lea has Asherman's
syndrome, a condition that will likely affect
Lea's fertility and ability to carry the baby
to term in "Boys Don't Cry."
Although they want to be parents, the pair
is understandably terrified when Lea gets
pregnant again in "Broken or Not," and their
fears are confirmed when they learn her uterus
is thinning and has a high probability of
rupturing.
Shaun devises a surgical plan to increase
their odds, but while recovering in the hospital,
Lea experiences a bleed from her scar tissue.
In "Quiet and Loud," Glassman tells Shaun
that Lea and the baby will survive only because
they were already in the hospital for Shaun's
procedure.
Among the many difficult figures Shaun encounters
while working at St. Bonaventure, few are
more divisive than Dr. Jackson Han, played
by Daniel Dae Kim, whose arrogance as a surgeon
is unrivaled among the staff.
After Marcus Andrews ascends to hospital president,
his position is filled by Dr. Han, who finds
Shaun's interactions with other staffers and
patients inappropriate for a position in surgery.
After Shaun upsets a mother with an inconvenient
truth about her infant, Han confronts him
only to be dumbfounded at Shaun's lack of
social awareness about his own interaction
with the young resident in "Risk and Reward."
Despite Shaun's colleagues' insistence that
he is working on social cues, Han feels Murphy
isn't fit for the role of surgeon.
After telling Shaun he is a remarkable diagnostician,
Han moves him into the pathology department,
believing it's a better fit for Shaun's social
skills.
For Shaun, who has dreamed of becoming a surgeon
since his youth, the move is a bitter pill
to swallow.
In "Breakdown," Shaun is brought in to consult
on a later surgery at Melendez's request.
He confronts Han about getting his job back
but ends up having a meltdown and that gets
him fired.
"I am a surgeon!
I am a surgeon!"
Han's handling of the Shaun situation widens
the rift between himself and Andrews, who
ends up firing Han and getting Shaun his old
job back in "Trampoline."
With all Shaun and Lea go through together,
it's nice to see them finally get their happy
ending.
However, because it's The Good Doctor, even
their wedding turns out to be a tricky affair.
After struggling to heal from their tragic
pregnancy loss, the episode "Vamos" sees Shaun
and Lea get engaged while on a medical mission
in Guatemala.
By the time of their engagement party, everyone
is looking forward to the upcoming nuptials,
but the stress of wedding planning already
has Lea struggling in "New Beginnings."
If that wasn't enough pressure, they agree
to be part of a streaming reality series culminating
in an onscreen wedding.
However, when the big day comes, they hate
everything about it and decide to cancel their
wedding moments before showtime.
Just when it starts to seem like they'll never
tie the knot, Shaun and Lea decide to get
hitched in a courthouse wedding.
Before they can, Dr. Glassman and Jordan throw
together a surprise rooftop wedding with all
of their friends present.
It's a perfect moment for an unconventional
couple, even if their fairy tale ending is
cut short when the hospital goes on lockdown.